à la 6 les fêtes sont toujours célébré
dignement
ici l'on a déjà chanté noël partager un
repas de fête et aujourd'hui ce sont les
paniers cadeaux des bénévoles qui sont
distribués à tous quatre-vingt onze
paniers réalisé avec soin à temps de
leurs bénéficiaires
[Applaudissements]
pepito va trouver des affaires de
toilette des vêtements des friandises de
noël cette année la moitié des paniers a
été réalisé en classe par des élèves de
primaire et de collège
merci c'est super chrono je sais pas je
suis et comprendre les cette année
patrick est vraiment fasciné par ces
cadeaux imagination des enfants ça c'est
ouvert ça il ya la serviette
il ya le sprite il ya une cymbale ya une
tasse il ya du cassoulet et même du café
espresso
ils ont pensé un peu ça me met du du
sucre sucre de canne 1 un petit sachet
qu'ils soient résidents
ils sont 70 ou visiteur habitué chacun
des bénéficiaires est appelé avec humour
et affection yann l'animateur social
montre à chacun qu'il fait partie d'une
famille singularité sur ce personnage à
part entière qui ont tous quelque chose
à donner quelque chose qui peut qui
ruine chez eux ils méritent d'avoir un
moment un moment comme cela moment qui
les valorisent qui les met en valeur
très discrète soutien bénévole à
l'origine de ces paniers depuis trois
ans savoure le moment on n'a pas de mot
on n'a pas de mot en soi sans empathie
on les regarde avec beaucoup
d'émerveillement ferney aussi aux échos
demain
ces hommes et ces femmes porteront une
chemise 9 un chapeau 9
de quoi se sentir un peu neuf aussi
là